hello everyone i would like to welcome
you to the kaijan digital insights
webinar on human somatic mutation
database
harnessing insight from real-world
oncology cases
and kaizen knowledge to annotate
variance and ss prevalence introducing a
new somatic database our best kept
secret
my name is megha balanadu and i'll be
your host and moderator for today
during the presentation please use the
ask the question box on the right of the
slide window to post your questions to
our speaker and kaijun experts which
will then be answered throughout the
session
we will also have a q a at the end of
the presentation
please also check out our resources
section for important links
with that i would like to introduce our
speaker for today dr biara litzenberger
vyada is the global product director of
oncology for clinical decision support
software and interpretation services at
kyogen
prior to joining the kaijin team viata
led clinical decision support and
interpretation of patient cases for
several next generation sequencing
protocols at
md anderson cancer center
piata earned her phd in molecular
genetics from the university of akun
in germany and was a national cancer
institute supported post-doctoral fellow
in the department of clinical cancer
prevention at md anderson cancer center
and now i will hand the presentation
over to biara thank you
thank you so much for the nice
introduction and thank you all for
attending today
kaijan's curated knowledge can be used
for many purposes
however
we have particularly deep curation in
the area of cancer research
as you know cancer is a disease caused
by mutations
while the majority of cancer is caused
by spontaneous or somatic mutations
many cancer relevant or
cancer-associated variants can also be
inherited
to understand the complexity of cancer
genetics and the oncogenic potential of
imitation
a resource is needed that covers both
types of mutations and hsmd fulfills
that need
datasets such as a tcga or icgc provides
opportunities to identify causative
variants underlying human cancers
however most of the somatic mutations do
not have a noticeable effect
and are so-called vos's
the prevalence of vos's in a cancer
sample hamper the distinguishing of
cancer-causing driver mutations
many approaches and databases have been
developed to prioritize cancer driver
mutations
most of these tools can be classified
into three categories based on three
basic principles
frequency-based methods which consist of
identifying mutated mutations
that are more frequently muted than the
background mutation rate
while this method is an essential step
at
identifying driver mutations as a
standalone measure it is not sufficient
and can be confounded by the fact that
mutations can generally occur with a
high frequency in the general population
the second principle is based on
computational algorithms that have been
developed to predict whether imitation
is deleterious
or pathogenic based on concepts
including evolutionary conversation
conservation
structural constraints
and the
physiochemical attributes of amino acids
but cancer driver mutations predicted by
these computational methods like
consistencies and are prone to false
positives or negatives
the third method is purely manual
research by subject matter experts
sifting through the literature to find
publications that describe statistically
powered experiments
that decipher the biological clinical or
disease relevance of mutation
this is an unsustainable laborious
effect that is not scalable
over the last years many tools such as
omg kb by cancer genome or jackson ckb
have been developed to deposit curated
variants with evidence-based information
about clinical somatic mutations into a
database
however they have limited number of
variants some of them less than 10 000
mutations have been annotated towards
its biological clinical or disease
relevance
as a scientist keeping pace with new
discoveries is a serious bottleneck and
i hope this picture literally
speaks to the problem that we face as
scientists
is that valuable information can go
undetected due to inadequate data mining
and variant interpretation mechanisms
while mutation and gene prevalence
remain one of the measures to identify
driver mutations it is important to use
different genomic oncology data sets to
calculate frequency data depending on
the goal of your research study
now hsnb is powered by the kyogen's
aggregated genomic knowledge base
since more than 20 years hydrogen's
subject matter experts and ontology
engineers have been using sophisticated
curation tools and ontologies
to transform unstructured genomic and
cancer-related literature
into machine-readable units with
semantic consistency
the aggregated structured genomic and
cancer-related knowledge comprises of
biological phenotypic therapeutic and
outcome data that can be used to
understand the genetics of a disease
review available therapeutic options
decide on experimental strategy or use
this data as part of accelerating a drug
development program
so how does kaiju transform unstructured
data into computable units
this is accomplished through a unique
knowledge-based model
expert curators which are phd and md
level
read the scientific literature including
figures tables and supplementary
information
and use rigid curation protocols to add
each relationship
such as an alteration clinical effect
drug disease association
into
a structured format in the knowledge
base
now we can use these relationships
and units to compute the functional
impact and actionability for each
variant and display variant and
disease-specific information in hsmd
in addition we use nlg processing to
return in a human readable sentence the
essence of an experiment for example a
functional study or a clinical trial
result from a paper
the kite knowledge based model allows us
to answer unexpected questions because
the database can can transverse indirect
relationships
build new relationships and can find
unexpected connections
for simplicity the most relevant
interconnected aspects that can be
explored in hsnd are shown here
this data set is genomically described
by refseq and assembled transcripts and
is currently available in genome bill 37
their clinical oncology data set
comprises of over 300 000 de-identified
patient cases and we capture age and
gender of the patient
the interconnections between
a variant
the tumor type and investigational
or approved drugs allows us
allows the user to explore therapeutic
relations
the mutation
has been characterized
by four measures
actionability classification according
to the amp asco cup guidelines
an activation type
a molecular function summary
population impact and biochemical impact
all relations are backed up by
references for the user to transparently
review the evidence
so what are the sources that establish
those relationships and how many
relationships can be assessed through
hsmd
as of today hsmg contains
over nearly 3 million curated alteration
findings this number goes up during
weekly updates
the data with nhsnp is derived from a
combination of information from the
collider knowledge base
observed clinical cases
as well as public databases
used to annotate variants
these resources are combined
to bring a wealth of usable trustworthy
information regarding the biological
clinical and the disease relevance of an
alteration to view
again this information comes with
appropriate citations for transparently
transparency
now
currently the curated data characterizes
over a million unique variants
encompassing a thousand four hundred
different genes
and nearly eleven thousand cancer types
subtypes and heritary cancer syndromes
now
i want to
talk
a little bit about the observed clinical
case data set
how is this
clinical data set
derived
for more than a decade carjen's
professional interpretation team
consisting of
phd level scientists as well as a team
of collaborating oncologists
have been researching and interpreting
somatic variants reported in cancer
patients
this clinically observed ngs data is
derived from a number of clinical
testing labs using a variety of
different sequencing panels
the manual variant interpretation
includes the activation type
written out reference supported
molecular function statements
and actionability according to the
astro-cap guidelines
the range of tumor types includes
solid tumors lymphomas and hematological
malignancies
this dataset is constantly growing and
will add about
70 000 new cancer profiles annually into
hsmd including 6
60 000 new curated variants
within oncology a number of different
aggregators publicly or privately have
emerged and each of the data
sets has its own strengths and
limitations
some data sets may be larger than others
but like a biological or clinical
annotation
other data sets may be biased towards a
certain disease
so in some cases
combining data sets together can reveal
novel insights
as an example how does the hsmd dataset
differentiate from tcga
now it is important to
recognize that the kaiju data set has a
larger sample size
it is more diverse
and reflects a patient population that
tends to be post-treatment
the tcga data set contains a huge number
of variants noticeably due to bioacids
and polymorphisms whereas in contrast
hsnp's dataset contains
more than 260 000 unique variants
primarily enriched for presumed
clinically relevant mutations
so if you ask the question what are
potential acquired resistance mutation
that may occur due to extensive
treatment
you will likely not find the answer
using tc2a where the dominant samples
were derived from treatment naive cancer
patients
what i'm trying to illustrate is that it
is important to recognize that
characteristics of
the data set that that the
characteristics of the data set
should be used optimally to answer
scientific questions
now this graphic represents
the number of cases tested for
each of the genes comprising hsnp's data
set in blue compared to cosmic sample
coverage from their targeted screen data
which is in red
hsnv contains a large number of cases
tested for each gene providing a meme
for a robust and confident assessment of
gene and variant prevalence from
clinical derived cancer cases
how can you access
hsmd and its first version that we're
releasing
the kaijin oncology data set can be
accessed via a searchable interface
the interface allows for flexible
searches by a specific term such as a
variant gene drug or disease or searches
across the data set
so let's live into the application and
within the next 10 to 15 minutes i will
walk you through some of many use cases
hsmd can answer
this screenshot represents an interface
of our gene explorer which allows for
exploring and prioritizing a list of
genes with specific attributes
that are listed within each column
the colored bars visualize the overall
genetic characteristic of a gene based
on the curated mutations
within each gene shown in the third
column
for example the functional column
in the middle shows the proportion of
mutations in each gene which contains
known functional impact classifications
hovering over each colored bar will show
the details of the distribution that
makes up the genetic characteristics of
each gene
all data in hsnb is hyperlinked for you
to dive deeper into a gene barrier drug
trial or disease and respective
references
so what can you do with this information
if an oncogene or tumor suppressor
status is not established
one can predict a potential status based
on the general composition of the
alteration types activation status and
tier classification
one can also
filter and sort this data set to
prioritize a list of genes that are
non-tumor suppressable
oncogenes with known functionally
impactful mutations and are clinically
relevant
one can derive a list of
genes that contain mature mutations that
cause for example splicing defects
or prioritize based
on known functional impact
specifications
one can also ask which genes on my panel
are actual
or
which oncogenes are targeted with the
most
or least
drugs
the barrel explorer allows you to
explore and prioritize a list of
variants with specific attributes
each vein is described with its
impact
function actionability
with how many diseases it is associated
and how many associations from the
literature are available for each
variant
the columns allow you to identify
if we have seen this variant in our real
world oncology data set
and that's in the last column called
clinically observed or if it's derived
from our knowledge base
through literature curation
one can interrogate the variance by
asking questions such as
what are the missense mutations with a
known biological or clinical relevance
that have been clinically observed
or
which biological relevant mutations have
associated therapies or trials
which biological relevance are emerging
biomarkers without associated therapies
which variants have been most or least
characterized in the literature
and among those variants that are vos's
which ones associate with a lot of
literature
the alteration explorer also provides
the mean to search on a codon position
to identify how many variants we have
observed at the location
how they were classified
and
if we have seen them in our clinical
data set
or in our collagen knowledge base by
proactively curating the literature
you can explore hsmd from a disease
perspective as well
for example you could ask the questions
which diseases are commonly mutated by a
specific gene
which cancer types have
we observed in our clinical data set
that are not associated with clinical
trials or drugs
or
what are the diseases that have been
associated with the most or least
variants
now i will take an example of a gene
called btk button torrence and kinase to
walk you through the specific gene and
variant content in hsmd
first of all the left side contains
headers that serve as navigation pane
and allows you to easily and quickly
navigate through the gene
or variant content
the gene summary allows you to quickly
understand its function and
if somatic or german mutations have been
associated with a hereditary syndrome or
solid or hematological malignancy
various link outs exist to other
databases such as ingenuity pathway
analysis to understand in which pathway
this gene is located
the subsequent section provides an
overview of the alteration types and
functional impact distributions with
energy
you can easily find out what are the
known activating mutations by clicking
on the number
which then navigates you
to
the alteration section
who then displays those nine
mutations that are known to be
activating
alternatively you can ask the question
what are what what kind of alteration
types are frequently observed
such as uh missense nonsense uh indulge
et cetera
and among
a specific alteration type in this
example missense mutations
how many are known to be activating or
predicted activating
the alterations section will
automatically display
just the transmutation
and filtering capabilities
allow you to select only activating or
predictive activate mutations and in
this example you can see that
we have identified 400 activating or
predicted activating mutations in btk
but what are really the affected codons
in a gene of interest at which mutations
occur are there any hot spots
hsmd displays a lollipop graphic
that allows you to identify
where in the gene
and how often we have observed clinical
cases with a specific mutation at that
codon
and then when hovering over the lollipop
you can determine the amino acid
position for this hot spot
now you may want to review in which
diseases is ptk predominantly mutated
in this example
cll
and cll sll is showing up as the top
disease frequently mutated
if you don't
see a disease in the top 10 on the
screen you can either use the arrows to
navigate through those 34 diseases in
which kaiju has observed
this gene to be mutated in
alternatively
you can use the search box or
sort a table
by the represented columns to answer
additional questions such as how many
cases in each disease were tested for
this gene
now for a particular disease of interest
such as
cll it is important to understand the
overall mutational landscape of this
disease
this is the disease page for cll
the disease page provides detailed
information about disease
and several sections shown here on the
left
the gene prevalence
in this particular disease is described
in the gene distribution section
allowing you to understand
what are the top mutated genes
alteration types and variants in this
disease
after determining now that btks we go
back to our example it's not one of the
top 10 mutated genes
you may be wondering how actual actually
is this gene
what are really the most clinically
significant mutations within vtk
hsnb provides for each variant an
actionability classification based on
the amp guidelines which determines the
therapeutic prognostic or diagnostic
importance of a variant
we can then plot the actionability
across the different alteration types in
this gene
and this graphic here provides an
overall assessment
how actionable a gene is if it is rather
an emerging gene
or if the actuality is driven by a small
or large number of variants in a
specific alteration type
now there are nine mutations that stand
out to be clinically relevant
and these nine mutations all occur on
the same codon that we have previously
identified as hotspot in this gene
now
if those variants are clinically
relevant
are they actually targeted drugs
that
that can be used
or do those variants cause resistance or
drug
the drug section provides a list of
drugs its targets and a therapeutic
response related to a specific disease
the information you will find in this
case of btk is that there are three
drugs that are approved by an agency
fda
ema as well as the pmda
um
that that
that target btk
however the specific hotspot at codon
4d1 causes resistance to ppk inhibitors
identified in a variety of diseases
i mentioned that each relationship is
associated with a references and if you
use
the drop down next to each drug
you will find the relevant papers and a
summary statement to support this
relationship
now
if we want to know more about
a particular mutation
to understand what is the biological
impact and how frequently is the
specific variant really observed
you can dive into a variant page
for each mutation hsmd organized the
detailed information about the variant
in several sections shown on the left
the description is an expertly written
summary
of the molecular function backed up by
hyperlinked references for your review
what you can find out in this case is
that btk mutations
that cause resistance
um cost resistance at this residue c 480
and it is a residue that is a binding
site for btk inhibitors and if it's
mutated decreases the binding
of
those btk inhibitors
hsmd displays the detailed genomic
description
where this material is located
and its nomenclature
based on
different refseq and ensemble
transcripts
now alternatively hsmd allows you also
to identify and confidently distinguish
variants of uncertain significance from
those that may have clinical relevance
so
in this case of this
second btk mutation that i'm showing
here on the screen our variant scientist
experts did a targeted curation of this
variant
and specifically researched the
literature and database sources and
determined an unknown impact
many cancer associate bearings have been
primarily studied in a heritage cancer
or inherited disease context
hsnd provides comprehensive literature
coverage
about
a variant including literature related
to graduate cancers or inherit diseases
that could be that could shed
a light into a potential role in cancer
in this example we have a clinically
observed btc mutation
however
a role in cancer has not been
established yet
but it has been rather associated with
an x-linked agama glugolinium
anemia
disease in humans
if you're not familiar with this
specific
heritage disorder
you can research the varying
bibliography for articles describing
this mutation in association with the
syndrome
and hypothesized a potential role of
this mutation in
tumorigenesis
now
going back to the example of the
c481 hot spot
you may want to ask what is the most
prevalent disease in which this mutation
has been observed
data can be reviewed in the observed
clinical case distribution section
additionally disease associations can
also be derived by searching through the
bibliography to find additional
relationships
so how does hsmd
characterize rare variants
with early clinical and or pre-clinical
actionability information
this here is a tier 2 variant
which means it is potentially clinically
relevant mutation
it has been described as a
non-activating mutation
and the description typically describes
early results
or case studies with a potential
response
the fact that this is a rare mutation is
supported by the frequency calculations
from our data set
within the drug section
case studies are captured that describe
the treatment outcome of a specific
cancer type hovering this mutation
however what you can see here is that
for this mutation
it is not established that the mutation
sensitizes the tumor to this drug
but
this is exactly being investigated and
tested right now in clinical trials for
lymphoma plasma cell myeloma and solid
tumors
now hsne can also link
directly to external databases and
incorporates population frequency data
from nomad
which can be transparently reviewed to
determine if a polymorphism is
predominantly present in a specific
population
likewise the variant page displays a
variety of prediction tools which may be
used as supporting avalanche evidence to
evaluate a biological role of a mutation
separately from
understanding a gene or
variant
involvement in cancer hsmd contains a
clinical trial portal
that allows you to search globally
clinical trials based on specific search
criteria such as a gene a phase
recruitment status
a specific drug
country or city range
each trial record
if you click on the record it describes
the trial details it's location
and
eligible alterations
drugs and diseases
now
um in cases you want to understand more
about the drug itself that's being
investigated
it's general development status
you'll be able to
click on the drug
and
from the drug page you can derive
the
development status
brightness synonyms
and also different drug targets
um
and and potential clinical trials where
this drug is involved in
in summary hsmd contains
a comprehensive oncology dataset
that gives you access to a rapidly
growing real-world oncology dataset and
structured current evidence
the content is updated weekly to cope
with increasing number of variants
literature sources and changing clinical
relevance
the first version of hsmd will be
developed in an easily accessible user
interface
i hope that with the use cases today i
could show you that hsmv allows you to
spot key mutations with driving
properties or clinical relevant
relevance
that the comprehensive aggregation of
structured content can bring valuable
scientific information
to your attention that can be used to
accelerate new discoveries
or new drug development programs
and to interpret confidently clinically
relevant mutations
kaijun has been curating and organizing
clinical data for decades and we would
be very happy to be your partner by
providing access to our high quality
trustworthy updated and comprehensive
content in a way that suits your
individual needs
please visit our websites to request a
free trial access thank you so much for
your attention and time today
thank you for that informative
presentation viara
with that let's straight away jump into
q a i see a lot of questions coming
our first question here is
have you calculated co-occurring genes
and variants and is that is that data
available in hsmd
we have done internally our calculations
uh especially on corcoran genes
however we have not yet implemented the
results of this analysis within hsmd
okay
how often is this database updated
yeah i mentioned this initially in my
slides so hsmd variant curation content
is updated weekly
um
the clinical case data set
and externally incorporated databases
such as nomad or hmhgmd are updated
quarterly
and within hsmd we do expect to add
about 5 000 new curated mutations per
month
and about 70 000 clicker cases annually
will this data be available in gr38
so the initial version um was built um
based on the genome bill 37 um
we plan to lift it over to uh gf-38 next
year um for your use
okay um let's see will this data set be
available as download
yeah that's a good question so um the
initial version is an online version our
plans are to expose our content through
the api next year
if people need early access
we do have a solution through services
for
select customers
next question is you mentioned that each
assembly is updated weekly how do you
ensure that the content is up to date
yeah that's a good question um so um our
content creation team has nightly
sophisticated queries that are run on
pubmed
guidelines and labels
and this identifies a set of new
articles or references which are then
further processed through a screening
process
and um which may eventually end up in
the task class list of a curator who
then categorizes the article such as a
treatment study or functional study
or review and then depending on
the broad category whilst this to a
subject matter experts to curate
relevant information
um all variants um
that have been clinically observed at
least twice over the last year
will undergo a deep review process to
gather the latest evidence to decide if
the activation type the molecular
function summary and actionability is up
to date
we have some time left to take a few
more questions
the next question is do you use ml and
crowdsource data for variant curation
um the answer to crowdsourced data is no
um we only
have our internal curation team that
will uh curate information
um according to the same standard
now the second part of this was do we
use machine learning methods and um
i can maybe have maybe have time to
explain it a little bit more in depth so
the curation of the data
at scale is very
complex and carjen uses various methods
whenever appropriate without
compromising the position of it
so
the process in general of clinically
clinical and phenotypic data curation is
very laborious and
intellectually intensive activity that
demands deep subject matter expertise
and significant personal resources
however um it is important to recognize
that using the most appropriate method
at each step in the curation process is
critical for operating at scale
and
being able to curate so much data for
more than one million variants in hsnd
so for example
the process of identifying and quickly
prioritizing relevant publications for
curation
is commonly carried out by queries
by current articles in pubmed
and
machine learning is providing a valuable
approach to enhance and accelerate this
initial
prioritization process
now
using the like natural language and
processing and
machine learning approaches you can
further facilitate certain seeding
relationships from articles
however um
in general
the deeper curation
requires
to build requires height to to dig into
highly unstructured data like graphics
full text supplementary materials
and
to decipher complex clinical outcomes
and phenotypic relationships require
human judgment
and therefore our experts really focus
on the human judgment the human curation
to
provide accurate
relevant
information
and capture these complex relationships
and interactions and even contradictory
evidence
so if you would do the last step with
machine learning you would certainly
lose position
and
the manual curation for kaiogen is
still the the gold standard
to capture these complex
relationships
next question
when will hsmd be available and is there
a way to try it out
yep hsnb will be available at the end of
this year
um
a trial can be requested for a limited
period of time
on our websites
will you be able to overlay the content
with patient data such as age for
example to review mutations in pediatric
patients
yeah that's a good question so we do
have the capabilities to do that
however this will not be part of the
first release
you showed examples of just variants
does hsmd include fusions or cnvs
yeah currently the interface only
displays small mutations however we do
plan to add uh fusion and copy number
content in our next release
all right
before we conclude i would like to thank
our speaker dr biata litzenberger and
most of all you our audience for your
attention
we hope this was informative and helpful
however if you should have any remaining
questions please do not hesitate to
contact us we are here to help you
this concludes today's session on hsmd
we look forward to hosting you in future
cajun digital insight webinars have a
pleasant rest of your day thank you